hello welcome back to big mood everybody
we got the whole gang here
hello introduce yourself [ __ ] hola
soy tiffany
uh hi bang bangla gina you're so
cute you saw americano
what was that i am american nikki i know
but uh
you're not spanish you're supposed to
i'm not i'm uh
brown i'm brown how do you say that how
do you say
okay so you like your boobs you want
them comfy put on a third love bra
i mean i'm actually wearing third love
right now oh yeah
oh i know that one i like that model i
love what i'm wearing actually
i'm not going to show you them dude give
us a little give us some action give us
just kidding it's really comfortable
though super quality comfort
they do a fitting room quiz to make sure
it fits your boobies just right
any issues you have with your current
bras will be removed
and you deserve it you deserve some tlc
that's third love comfort
go to thirdlove.com big mood now to get
20 off your first purchase
that's thirdlove.com big mood for twenty
percent off today
cover them pearly is over here [ __ ]
tips
on my shirt they're perfectly placed
tip has pearls right over her nipples on
her shirt
when they get piercings on their nipples
why don't i ever see pearl ones that'd
be sick
oh that would be sick right like a
barbell with purple mermaids
little mermaid
jewelry you make it oh i will okay these
are for your
nips these are for your lips so today we
thought we'd do a life update video
because
there's a lot of life updates that have
happened in the group especially
with two of our members half the group
um
let's start with jess though because you
just moved to a different state i did
i moved to austin i am a part of the
california wave
um excellent which is funny because
you're the one i was born in
austin but i said i would never move
back and she made a big fuss on twitter
yeah a huge fuss i did not i even posted
one thing
i even reposted it and argued it
and i was saying that i wanted to move
out of california because i was born
right now i was fighting you and i was
like you can't [ __ ] leave ballet
and then she's the one that moved a nice
stage
and people are mad probably because
people on the internet are never allowed
to change their minds no oh yeah
as soon as you make one known that's for
life you can't
change yeah so i don't know i'm i um i
i'm very much enjoying the beginning
part of my move i mean i've
just been there for like two weeks i got
my new apartment
back up though oh moving dead yes what
happened you did not enjoy
there were several things that happened
on my way out one of them being my move
didn't go so well because i got a pod
and uh there was some [ __ ] with that
the second being when i left i was stuck
in four hours of traffic because i
didn't realize i was
actually driving out of california on
memorial day weekend that was a whole
other thing took me four hours to get
out of l.a i told her not to move on
mercury retrograde but
nikki warned yesterday and she said that
it'd be okay
california kicked me on the way out
so i just make this [ __ ] suffer before
she goes yeah so when i got my
pod um i they sold it to me as this is
for one bedroom
it's not for a one bedroom it was for
like an efficiency size like a studio
size so i had to throw away a bunch of
[ __ ] you have to be a minimalist yeah
but it's okay because honestly like i
got
like now that i'm there and i got the
stuff that would fit and i got it in my
place like i'm happy with what i did get
to bring but the day of i was having
like a panic attack and luckily i asked
steve if he was free because one i
needed just male
presence in general because i had movers
like there and i just felt kind of a
little bit uncomfortable with strange
men
and then so just having steve's present
was was good also he like can carry
things yeah so like he's more healthy
he's more helpful than someone tiny like
tiff
yeah i'm pretty strong okay i know
you're strong but um you're not like a
six foot man so
no um because tiff and i were supposed
to go over yeah
but then we got called off yeah we were
on call and then we were
waiting we're just sitting around
killing time i'm like jess you know
because i made up the time and then it
seemed like it wasn't going to work for
everyone because i
originally i said can you guys come at
three and then i was like oh wait the
movers want to come at 12 and then you
guys were like well we're not quite
right we're like we'll still be there at
three
yeah exactly yeah we could have made it
at three and then yeah but then like
so half of my [ __ ] couldn't fit and i
was dealing with the stuff with c and
steve was like okay you're gonna have to
figure out what you need to throw away
or like instead of donating all your
nice stuff to be a tiffany
she chucked it down the garbage shoot i
love i mean i just had a truck
i love that i wasn't involved in this
moving process because they knew of
course
you were zero health for anything they
knew like even if i was there i'll just
sit on the couch and make it heavier
yeah yeah
gina's like her cat yeah she just makes
it difficult yeah
yeah you would have just gotten in the
way so me and steve
basically spent a couple hours chucking
chucking [ __ ] it was like a rage room in
the [ __ ]
down the street i hate hearing this part
because i'm like oh my god
you should have seen the joy in your
husband's face like i
he i was letting him throw stuff away
with me and then so like i would open
the shoot and kind of leave it open he
got to throw away my christmas tree
he was so happy to take that christmas
tree and [ __ ]
he was like winding up to slam [ __ ] down
the trash shoot like he took my pilot
rage dude
he took my pyrex [ __ ] like i just had
kitchen stuff like just so much
there was so much stuff that i threw
away but honestly it was just like i i
don't have room for it
it hurts it won't fit in my car it won't
fit in the pod what am i going to do it
hurts us more than you just
you don't understand a pyrex would fit
in my car that's like borrowed
12 you know like am i going to freak out
over 12. i'm just going to throw it away
like
what am i throwing away succulents
very last minute like i had to go she
was having panic attacks at the same
time
i didn't really have a panic attack but
i was like you know tell me you didn't
steve was there and he was like okay
what are you gonna do and i was like i
don't know
but like it you know and he just helped
me like sort through the i had to like i
had everything packed up and ready to go
then i had to like reopen boxes and like
figure out what i really needed he
didn't label anything which is shocking
i didn't label anything
because i thought i thought it was
always going to fit i was like i don't
need to care
make sense for you gina but just like i
know
it's shocking i know but so anyway that
debacle happened
and then yeah and now you're there yeah
and you like it
yeah yeah i really love my new apartment
it feels more homey to me
um and it's way cheaper and but it's
still really nice
it's really yeah i'm only an hour drive
from my dad now
high ceilings yeah i love you my
apartment i love it it's
it's outside of the austin i mean it's
an austin address but it's not like
in austin yeah proper so it's like kind
of in the hill country a little bit it's
really pretty
it's very quiet that's one thing i never
got in la was
quiet especially i cause remember the
first time i moved from like the
hollywood hills area over to the west
side i was like oh my god my neighbor
over here in the hollywood hills is just
so [ __ ] annoying and then so i moved
to marina del rey
and my neighbor below me was like
playing club music 24 7. i was like oh i
can't escape this
so many artists wanting to come here i'm
just like
and now i'm like in the hill country in
austin and it's quite as [ __ ]
so what is happening i got it gina is
always doing tip's hair
oh she knows long hair
she goes through like six different
hairstyles while she looks so mexican
with that yeah it does i know i thought
she was gonna do the like princess leia
which by the way the frida thing it was
uh it was actually inspired by a mexican
oh really uh warrior ladies i forgot
what they're called mexican warrior
ladies yeah
well those are stories okay so but
um one thing that you do have to deal
with now that you're moved is
coming back here to shoot once a month
yeah
and you on the plane ride had a
quite a time yeah so i i chose to leave
california where i still do have some
work that i have to do
move to another state where now i now
have to fly back once a month
but i also have like panic disorder and
uh it's triggered by airplane rides
so basically once a month i get to have
panic attacks um
by my own choice but uh if i take
exposure therapy it is
that's what i thought because i i didn't
used to have this and then when i
when i started traveling more with joe
for some reason like because we went to
japan three times we went to hawaii like
four or
five times we went to europe like we we
did all this stuff yeah
at some point i developed a panic
disorder on the airplane but prior to
that i didn't because you know me and
joe were dating long distance and i
would fly here every month and i was
nervous but fine but for some reason now
i have a panic disorder on an airplane
so i will have a panic attack at the
slightest
[ __ ] turbulence like oh like the
slightest like if you just blow on the
wing i will freak the [ __ ] out and start
like hyperventilating so this time i
didn't have the
the i what i had taken before was not
xanax but ativan but it's basically
xanax
it's same drug class different drug but
so i'd taken ativan before that helps my
panic disorder i only take it on
flights or like emergency situations
only but i didn't have any
so i was like you know i'm gonna get the
exposure therapy i'm gonna i'm gonna
take my flight back to la
without any drugs and the panic is
ensued like almost immediately so i
basically got up out of my seat at one
point
i was up in the [ __ ] galley with the
like air
flight attendants yeah and i was like
can you just talk to me because i'm
[ __ ] spiraling
i was like yeah and then so they were
really they were super nice and they
were talking like
i think i just need to like have someone
tell me that i'm not dying because in my
head i start to feel like
we're going down yeah but also i i think
a part of it is claustrophobia too
because
all the people around me like all the
rows in front of me at
in my rows and then behind me they all
had their windows closed i can't [ __ ]
handle that like i need to be able to
see the ground so unless you're all
wearing masks like it just feels very
like
the mask didn't have anything to do with
it i need to be able to see the ground
no i need to see like you can't tell
where you are i can't tell where i'm at
i can't tell like i mean it's a plane it
crashes you can see the plane under the
ground pretty quickly yeah yeah
that's fine i i just i need to see the
ground
i don't know what it is like i'm not
afraid of heights when i see
the the the ground and i feel the
turbulence at the same time if i can see
the ground i know that we're not
actually like falling out of the sky
it's just relevance to yeah how about
like you know when terp
turbulence is like because you're going
up and down you feel like that drop
feeling sometimes like what if you just
focus on okay i don't have that drop
feeling in my stomach right now so we're
not falling
no it's not about the drop necessarily
it's like i just need to see the ground
if i can see the ground i'm fine
but um i bought my tickets i bought them
for june july and august ahead of time
and they were all
full i even got i got the front of the
plane like it's row nine or something
but like the window seats were all full
already for all of those flights
and so i was like sitting in a row where
i couldn't control the window
and so i freaked out and then so i got
moved to another row where i could see
out the window a little bit that helped
a little bit but
yeah basically i had to get out of my
seat and like talk to someone i was just
like
kneeling in the [ __ ] galley like
freaking the [ __ ] out so and i was like
i'm gonna have to get drugs before i
take my return flight like
i have to get them because i just can't
i don't know what it is i just can't
handle it oh yeah but like the second
half of the flight and the descent and
the landing i'm totally cool with like i
might drink
this baby on the ground it doesn't work
no oh no alcohol doesn't work
no it knocks me out literally only
like a benzo will stop the panic crazy
yeah that's intense yeah but the second
half of the flight like once there's
only an hour left
then i know the descent is like 20
minutes of that so i was like i'm like
okay 40 minutes left 40 minutes left
you're like counting down
yeah so i got through the i like landing
because i guess even landing could be
the more dangerous part of the flight
yeah
it is actually most crashes but i feel
that i'm like put this baby on the
ground like the closer to the ground we
get the the better i feel i'm like i
don't care if we
bounce and hit the runway slide i don't
care if they got to come in sideways and
you know if i can drop that [ __ ] in the
wind like just put me back on the ground
like i love the descent i don't care i'm
the opposite
i hate takeoff and landing i hate i
could fly forever but the takeoff and
landing
yeah i don't i just don't like being up
there i don't like the beginning in the
middle what have you played a mobile
game
i try but it's like best fiends
not our sponsor anymore at least not for
this video yeah but
um so yeah but overall uh i did have a
little bit of a debacle at my new
apartment i think i might be on a list
what what are you carrying out i bitched
out
i think the guy might be a gay guy too
so we were just [ __ ] getting real
[ __ ]
oh my god i love it so i
had a pod right and i and no one told me
this but when i first arrived i was like
okay i have my pod working and putting
goes oh those aren't allowed here and i
was like well [ __ ]
uh it's coming and no one told me you
knew i was moving from out of state so
he's like okay well we'll find a
place for it or whatever you can find
you know go here go hear whatever well
it turns out like i actually rented a
garage they have garages at this complex
and there's a parking spot in front of
the garage and you have the garage so
i put my pod in my parking spot that's
in front of my garage that i'm renting
but um so the day that it was getting
delivered
they had you know the truck has to kind
of like move forward in order to back
into
yeah but the maintenance drove by and
thought that we were dropping it
where they had pulled forward which is
like in front of a bunch of cars
and so like he his little [ __ ] ass
drove his little [ __ ] golf cart to
the front desk and was like they're
putting a pod behind
a bunch of cars like that's you can't do
that
you care about me so until the front
desk guy calls and he goes
hey i just wanted to check and see like
are you dropping your pod like behind
all the cars
and i was like [ __ ] no i'm not what
makes you think i'm an idiot i can't
believe i just
probably insulted my intelligence yeah i
was like
do you think i'm an idiot that i would
drop the pod and like right behind a
bunch of parked cars like obviously the
pod stays there for like 24 hours or
more
but it's so personal yeah i was like i
was mad because how dare you
i saw the maintenance guy and he saw me
and i'm like you think i'm an idiot
you think i'm an idiot she's like i
think i'm gonna list now yeah yeah yeah
no i'm sorry who remembers his face no
that's not even the end of the story
so i hung up on the front desk guy and
then he emails me and he goes
oh i think we got disconnected like
sorry i didn't mean to like offend you
or whatever
and so i wrote back oh no
yes i already know where this is
the person with you yes you should have
sent it
um okay i said the first thing i okay
this is this is the email i could
probably even get it
out on my phone and read it okay yeah
i'm gonna read the email
and you guys heard our last email
you guys are gonna kill me when you oh
my god i'm already
nervous yeah me too okay jess is angry
this is what he's writing you're so
similar but i'm the one that talks them
down and it's like yeah we're just gonna
neutralize all of it
yeah you really do okay i'll read what
he wrote after i after i hung up on him
he said hello jessica i'm not sure what
happened but our call got dropped
yeah [ __ ] i hung up and i know you have
a lot going on with moving i just wanted
to reach out like you know i did not
call to say you were dropping off the
pot in the wrong area i was calling to
make sure you were where
your pot was getting dropped off i was
like [ __ ] yes there was i was there the
driver was there my dad was there like
the maintenance guy's just a [ __ ]
[ __ ] so i'm more mad at the
maintenance guy than i am the front desk
um so but anyway you're gonna kill the
messenger okay yeah basically i
i i took a shotgun and blasted the
messenger's face off that's very texas
it's very texas
when you move back to texas they give
you a shotgun yeah yeah i got my
standard shotgun
like in hawaii
they have a strap in the truck and they
put it over your neck yeah texas
yeah all the bullets yeah instead of
aloha says howdy
yes so basically his email goes on a
little bit more and then he's like
please let me know if you need anything
again i'm sorry if you're offended
in my rage in my blind rage i wrote back
there's two things i don't like coming
from a man
oh my god
what the [ __ ] the first she's always she
brings
gender into the first is to waste my
time the second is to insult my
intelligence
i saw magnets on the golf cart drive by
i was standing
right there with the pods delivery
driver as well as my dad in plain sight
the pods
truck driver obviously had to pull
forward in order to back up the
maintenance guy could have easily said
where are you dropping this at directly
to me and avoiding this colossal waste
of time
they turned on me and i doubled down
damn girl
wow and on that note we have a sponsor
today
it's stitch fix a nice outfit we'll help
you
help you calm down girl oh my god stitch
face
shopping for new clothes can be time
consuming
and expensive okay anyway stitch fix
offers
clothing hand selected by expert style
for your unique size budget
and style um we know what stitch fix is
you guys have heard about this company's
been around for a while
i enjoy going on there and actually
buying stuff directly from their website
as well but
um they also have a stylist that will
compile a box for you
if you are too busy carrying out on
people
you have time to go shopping uh you can
use citrix
they'll send you some clothes you can
try them out if you don't like it you
could return it it's super easy to
return it they send you the
the pre-paid envelope and then you just
drop it off at the usps
if for whatever stuff you don't love but
the pieces you do love
um the there is a 20 styling fee for
each box but it gets
credited towards the pieces you keep
there are no hidden fees ever
you also don't have to sign up for a
subscription but you can have a
subscription basis where they send it to
you every month or however
you can make it seasonal yeah yeah but
also you can just do it like once in a
while
you are in complete control they also
have styles and clothing to fit any
occasion for women
men and kids they ship all over the us
and it's also available in the uk get
started today at stitchfix.com
mood and you'll get 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com mood for 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
that is stitchfix.com
mood and while you're looking great why
not have a beautiful smile to accompany
your
stylish wardrobe so candid
is are these clear liners they're
comfortable removable
and practically invisible to help
straighten your teeth
and they're super convenient
you know with braces because like my son
currently has braces and
he's not loving it um you know because
braces are so annoying
you have the wires you have like the
rubber bands if you need to wear the
rubber bands you can't remove them
whenever you eat yeah and food gets
stuck up in there and then when the food
is stuck in there
it ends up staining your teeth if you're
not good about it
yeah it's like gotta use a water pick
all kinds of stuff exactly your gums get
all swollen
so much work it's a lot of work but with
candid you don't have to worry about all
that mess
because once you're eating you can or
before you start eating you can take off
the candied
aligners and put them off to the side
and then have your mouth
free and you don't have to worry about
all that food getting stuck anywhere
they're super convenient and candid is
awesome because you get to do this
all from the comfort of your own home
you get linked up
with an actual orthodontist because
other companies they generally
generally use like general dentists but
not with candid candid only works with
orthodontist and the same orthodontist
who created your plan is with you from
start to finish so you'll never have to
wonder how you're doing
with your treatment the average candid
treatment is just six months so
you'll start seeing results way before
then and it costs
thousands less than traditional braces
so become your best you
start straightening your teeth today
right now you can save 75
on candid's starter kit go to
candidco.com
mood and use code mood that's candid
co.com
mood code mood take advantage of this
limited time offer to save 75
on your starter kit candidco.com
mood code move that's a lot of doll
hairs a lot of doll hairs
you know what gina what's up since
you're just talking
let me talk about your your new
lifestyle change let me tell you guys
something
all right let me tell you wrong pure
trauma your teeth look great though wait
what happened
when you first came in i was like wait
your smile looks different but i'm like
did i just forget
cute cute things you forget what your
face looks like
go to texas two weeks right i don't even
know asians anymore are you nikki
i can't i can't even like notice an
asian face it's just kind of blurry i'm
like wait
they all look the same
i said it not her don't cancel it uh
yeah so a couple things changed i
decided okay so for the longest time
i've always
one of my favorite aesthetics is like
pronounced canine teeth yeah i think i
have it's so cute yeah i think it's just
on the bottom two oh yeah you do i used
to have them i ground them down too
my teeth are straight as [ __ ] yeah
bottom yeah
yeah so i went to my dentist shout out
to dr
jin your hot dentist yeah dentex dental
in pasadena what's up
um she always flirts with her dentist on
instagram i'm sorry
way too hard is he married no he has a
girlfriend but that's my marketing plan
yeah yeah he's cute go look at him
okay um give some business yeah so i
started a new job i'll get into that
later and then this new job requires me
to be on
in front of camera a lot and i just want
like a nice bright smile
yeah so originally i just wanted to even
out my front teeth because i had really
small
teeth next to my big teeth they were
tiny that was what i did i have
i have two veneers right next to my big
teeth oh okay yeah yeah
so i was like yeah i remember that i
only have two just though just the
veneer
yeah so you got the the top row yeah the
top row
so i went to my dentist i'm like you
know what i'm gonna be on camera a lot
so i did a whole whitening series
and then we i wanted to even out my
teeth but i was like hey so
how do we feel about fangs because i
want things and i told him this from the
beginning he's like yeah i can do that
for you and the cool thing about him is
he's an actual artist he paints
oh cool and these are like composites so
they build on top and they mold on top
so
yeah a great artist knows how to mold
very well yeah so i got myself some
things it looks great so wait it's
bonding then
yeah okay yeah i didn't shave down my
real teeth or anything he just built on
top of it yeah yeah
yeah i got barbed veneers there well
these two are veneers and then she got
bonding on these on the fangs
oh no they're composite veneers oh
there's they're still veneers oh okay
is it porcelain it's not porcelain no so
they don't want to last it's not going
to last
no so these don't last as long like i
could break them if anything but yeah
or if you grind your teeth yeah like i
don't know i mean but then your regular
tooth is just there yeah so like it's
not
it's not going to look weird right
exactly yeah i didn't want to shave down
my
when you get veneers so you don't really
have to shave because i got mine done
uh by dr danny and beverly hills yeah i
love dr danny too so um
danny benyamini if anyone needs he's
right yeah but he's looking too
he's yeah he's also very happy calm down
you guys he's
hot dennis in l.a what do you think
though he's married though with kids but
yeah um it makes sense yeah so
they he didn't really have to shave mine
i mean because my the problem was they
were so small already
oh next to my big teeth so i you know if
they pop off if you had enough space
yeah i don't have any space between my
teeth i get all my cavities in between
my teeth oh my god
yeah i have to floss religiously because
yeah like no space yeah but you don't
normally have to shave that much off for
veneers a lot of times if the guy's good
at his job
i guess this was the easier one just to
build on top of it yeah mess with your
realtor so it's probably a little bit
less expensive too because it's not so
permanent
so i got these fang babies and then i
hit up my jewelers i can't remember
those girls oh my god oh
wow we're gonna have to redo those sorry
i'm gonna kill you
um so i got those done because i have a
new job yeah
congrats i am now the host of g4 tv
which is a gaming channel that i've
watched when i was a kid
yeah and like i'm i remember growing up
just like god i want to be on a gaming
channel
like olivia munn was like the hottest
thing yeah olivia munn got her start
there
like a tv channel guys yeah tv like real
like on the tv real life tv
like really on the tv like on the real
tv on the real real tv
so what is that and what does that mean
like what's the host of g4
so the host of gpa i mean like it's it's
everything gaming everything nerd right
yeah um where they're going to put us on
which show yet we
are not allowed to know yet um because
out of like hundreds and hundreds of
auditions i think only like like eight
people six or seven of us yeah
made it and so i got kasem's one too
yeah and so that's my new gig now and
it's cool i mean it's super fun
i i didn't realize how big this was
going to be until they were like gina
you're going to be on tv
and you're going to be on tv like often
yeah you know like you're gonna be on a
show
um because i'm filming i have a
full-time job now five days
so crazy today you're the first to work
you're the first one to leave the state
and you're the first one to get a
full-time job
right
i haven't had like a full-time schedule
since i was like 20 yeah working three
jobs which was like two decades ago it
was like
60 years ago back in when we were first
landed on the moon
so like it's such a huge change for me
because i've lived on like
real like degenerate gamer hours yeah
yeah you guys you were
streaming on facebook right or you're
not no longer doing that
um like i went from working go go
dancing to streaming everything was
always at night
yeah like nighttime i never had to drive
anywhere
i never had to sit in traffic now i have
to [ __ ] commute yeah
[Applause]
um and it's weird because like okay so
here's how little i drove before i had a
lease for three years before
at least you get like 12 000 miles a
year well you can choose how many miles
you want but yeah so mine was twelve
thousand miles a year i returned that
car after three years with only eleven
thousand
oh my god gina you probably didn't even
oh you should have sold that car not
returned it anyways i'm very upset
you could have gotten money back oh oops
don't turn at least another same way at
least
you could have gotten thousands of
dollars back
equity yes don't don't turn your lease
in you need to sell
it and get money back especially if you
have such low mileage
anyways um i didn't know this
you're about to get an email right now
i'll [ __ ] get an email
and two things i don't like in women
yeah yeah there's two things that
when they're [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you could sell it to a third party and
get money back when you turn it in you
actually
lose money anyways
it was it was just a honda so it's yeah
whoa
we like our little hondas okay i don't
care how much money i'm actually driving
my little
um so now i'm commuting
yeah it's weird it's super weird for me
to picture you guys
how do you feel mentally though like
having to get up and like go into a job
like having a team it's fun like it's
super fun because the team is fun the
production team's fun this is
basically my dream job yeah um would you
say like
um you like them better as friends is
that like your new friend group
um he's really worried about your baby i
don't like them
better than our group i i just like them
better than i like nikki
oh that's the thing yeah
she's gonna be in therapy for this later
because even though it's a joke she's
taking it personally
and then
[Laughter]
like when you have like a whole thing
going on and there's a whole team of
people like working together on
something the energy of that is usually
pretty cool
it's amazing and i remember the first
day because this was like a
month's long audition yes it was so long
and you don't know if you're going to
move into the next
step of the audition until like a month
later it's super long
that's great um so i started this
audition process like probably in august
of last year yeah i remember when you
first brought it up
and you were like you were nervous about
it but but then it was like i forgot
about it because
it's been so long yeah yeah and then i
found out with you guys when we were
going
to bear in march it was so cool
[Laughter]
so and i remember my first talk with him
when i sat down with the executives i
ended the call with
guys i just want to let you know that if
i get this job like 12 year old me is
going to lose
i'm going to cry and i got the job and
this is basically like my dream job
you know like it still hasn't really hit
me yeah until i guess like i see myself
on tv or whatever but this past week was
definitely my first week yeah um so it
was a week full commuting
um and it was very interesting i got to
learn the freeway
traffic hours and you know i've lived in
la for 15 years i've
never had to do this and i've i used to
pump gas once a month
i have like a eco-friendly car i popped
twice this week
wow and i'm like bitching like an old
lady like why are gas prices so high
yeah
[Music]
and then so i'm just like complaining
about gas prices now i'm like holy [ __ ]
i'm that person now
but it's been so fun because this week
they've set apart a week for us to do
all these crazy activities where we all
get to bond with our new team
yeah and everyone's [ __ ] incredible
yeah
incredibly talented phenomenal gamers
and it's i feel like i have a new family
yeah [ __ ] dope
um and the funny thing about this
because i remember tiff saying this a
long time ago
when jk party started transitioning from
crazy challenges to just
like board games and card games i was
like why like we had so much fun like
doing crazy [ __ ] and eating things well
because no one on staff like wanted to
do that [ __ ] anymore exactly so i
remember
tiff saying yeah you know we just we
were
we just felt like we were too old to do
these crazy things anymore like we're
getting to that age we can't do that
well here i am at g4 tv 31 years old i
had to take like
three shots of hot sauce oh my god i
puked three times wow
yeah but it was so fun you're having a
good time yeah for sure you get
complicated
so every time i have to do these
challenges i just hear tiff in the back
of my head like we're too old for this
like [ __ ]
i'm still here no you should have fun
for me it was like
week after week after week after week
after week and i'm like after like a
year
and you're just like i'm tired of
showing up and then and then going to
like house parties or like get togethers
afterwards
and then people would be like let's play
this game and i'm like
no
so like we're not really i don't know if
we're going to do that a lot for
the channel but um it was a good bonding
break
yeah so three days of challenges and i
was like jk party prepared me for this
this is my [ __ ] yeah so even though i
did throw up they're like are you okay
i'm like i'm great
like round two yeah round two um so
we're filming our new studios being
built we're projected to be on tv by
august maybe nice so and this is like i
didn't even realize this i was like so
what channel is g4
going to be on like you know they're
like no we have our own channel
birthday party watch parties right yeah
yeah
okay so we're gonna have our own channel
like mtv has our own channel like this
is going to be
like we're under a comcast and
everything it's going to be wild awesome
gina
so i'm scared also because it's like
this is a lot more eyes
yeah i have like a full management team
like watching over me now and it's just
like this is a huge transition from
digital to linear or whatever it is that
you call like i have you have a lot more
support
yeah with a team like that exactly like
i have people like oh what do you
i can literally just ask him for
anything like yeah we can get this done
for you i was like holy [ __ ] like
this is a full-on you can't request
things for your for your dressing room
like
like i only i require raspberries
baskets of raspberries
a runner a writer yeah yeah so i mean
chasm's on there
and i give us any other names uh avali
may incredible uh frost
she's a huge in the league of legends
community golden boy
big announcer um and then we have the
the legend or the legacy host from the
old g4
so i'm meeting my heroes that's so cool
my first dream was with adam sessler the
man that i watched every day after
school
wow that's so awesome gina
so baby jean is happy i know it's huge
like do you feel like you deserve it
because i want to make sure you feel
like you deserve it yeah
you totally do i have trouble with that
yeah i do
you know it's just i i can't believe it
yeah you do
you've worked your ass off with this
it's like it all came to a point now
yeah
so it's it's a huge transition in my
life and i love it so much
i'm just scared i'm not scared or
nervous that's natural you value
a lot it does become scary yeah yeah and
also anything new
is always gonna be scary because it's
kind of the unknown exactly and you want
it to succeed
because then it's like yeah you don't
want to get taken away from you that
it's been like
so such a cool thing yeah yeah so i've
made so many friends and i'm learning so
much but no no not a lot of friends
though no not that many [ __ ]
it was funny because i was talking to
like in my eight or nine years with
party
jk party i puked once in my one week
with you [ __ ] i threw it three times
oh my god
welcome to g4 so it's great i mean
it i i haven't taken the time to really
celebrate but i went to the mall
yesterday i bought myself some really
nice
nice that's awesome you deserve that
like
treat yourself thank you we should have
champagne or something
i'm sleeping at a very regular hour now
i don't think it's gonna be good for
your mental health yeah yeah not healthy
to be up
from you know until 6am every day yeah i
think creativity within a structure is
really good for you
yeah yeah yeah so i feel really hurt and
listen to you i'm sleeping at [ __ ] 11
o'clock at night waking up
look at you where are you it's gross you
have the sun
touching your skin right yeah i got into
church of gina and i
signed up for a specific branding a
specific image
and you've broken it i don't know my
deity is matching the insides
you're not allowed to change so that's
i'm a working woman now yeah you are
nice i get lunch breaks
do you get cigarettes weird yeah because
i'm like i'm not a smoker but i would
always ask for cigarette breaks because
it's not fair they're like why don't
these smokers get scared
hang out with all the grips
[Laughter]
yeah my gamer friends are now like jenna
where are you i'm like i'm sorry i don't
know why
you're abandoning us i'm sorry well tiff
yeah what's been going on in your life
well not as like
happy and exciting as these ladies yeah
um i actually
my half of my story was a karen story so
i'm crying don't worry about it
that's not that great i cry in my car a
lot um
yeah so i've actually so my april was
intense like i had a lot of stuff going
on in my life like all at one time
literally in one week yeah
everything just like [ __ ] smacked me
in the face
and i'm not gonna talk about all of it
but um i will share that
one of the things was um
my sister randomly hits me up
one day on a saturday morning she's like
hey
so grandma's in bad shape um you this is
my dad's mom
uh you should you should call her as
soon as you can because it seems like
these are her final days like she
she's unrecognizable right now so
apparently she had like two really bad
falls and the second fall she hit her
head really badly to the point where
she was unable to use her her right side
like her right arm and her right leg
and so at that point and my grandma
she's always been like
mega independent she's like a formidable
woman like she's just like
super proud that probably hurt like
inside more than the outside [ __ ] yeah
like it was her pride it was so bad
where she was like
begging to just die it was horrible and
so
after my sister lets me know that i'm
like screw a phone call i'm booking the
next flight so i actually flew out to
mexico
and i was there for four days and during
those four days that i was there
like i didn't i didn't post about this
anywhere like this is the first time i'm
talking about it but
uh yeah like being there and seeing my
grandma
it was like completely heartbreaking
because i had never
seen my grandma in that state and you
know we're all helping her like
like her having to wear you know diapers
now and like having to be helped to
take a bath and like help being fed and
it was just like
like it was pretty shocking yeah it was
just really really shocking and i was
just there just trying to
be like to help as much as i can but at
that same time luckily
everyone like she got a sister that flew
in from tj that she hadn't seen in like
11 years
and so like her sister was there for a
long time but she flew in that
time that i was there and so and then
my other sister my older sister who
lives on another side of mexico she
actually flew in after i left so
a lot of family has been going and
visiting her and taking care of her like
the entire family is like
taking turns on watching her because
we're scared of her falling
and like hurting herself again um and
yeah like right like before i took off i
ordered a whole bunch of stuff on amazon
to just like try to make
her life like a little easier help
people like helping her make it a little
easier
so yeah it's just been um that was
really rough with my grandma yeah
but luckily she has been getting
progressively better oh so she didn't it
wasn't her last days yeah it really
wasn't good
yeah so that's like the i totally
thought she passed yeah
no i had i thought she passed yeah yeah
thank god she hasn't yet that's awesome
she's able to move on her own at all yet
so that's the thing like she has now
regained the the strength at least in
her
in her right arm she's able to like pick
up cups now and like feed herself better
and another thing too like when i first
saw her her
mind was like scrambled like she
couldn't understand what was being said
to her she couldn't remember
like who i was um like her her mind
almost like she had a stroke or
something so that's what we found out
the last day i was there she got a
ct scan or what is it yeah a ct scan
and the doctor says she had like mini
strokes
in her in her brain and that's what
caused like her to not
yeah because usually not being able to
use half your body is like a sign of a
stroke
but the good thing is that oh so the
doctor recommended like you know just
play a lot of
movies from her time a lot of music from
her time to like help her regain
her memory and like she has been a lot
better and
her speech is a lot better because
before she would repeat what we would
say to her
like i'd be like like hi grandma how are
you and hugo hi grandma how are you hi
grandma how are you
like she would repeat it over and over
again but then she as
like as of now like she hasn't been
really doing that anymore so like she
has gotten a lot better
and i really think it was um it was just
like
the whole family coming through and and
showing her like we love you don't give
up
don't do like because she just laid
there by herself then she would have
probably never even tried
so yeah like that was hard in in like
last like the ends of april that's
already one big thing and then you have
several other things yeah and i had a
whole bunch of other stuff too um
i'm like which one should i share that's
up to you should we
we could take a look let's take a long
break you think about it yeah
let's talk about hair let's talk about
it yeah playing with it
playing with tiff's hair because it's so
healthy because why because she's his
function of beauty yeah
yeah she actually does switched over
function and beauty is the world leader
in fully customized hair care we like
customized stuff i feel like it's the
era of customization you smell mine
uh they create your oh what is that
what's the eucalyptus one oh that's nice
it's my favorite they create your unique
formula based on a short but thorough
quiz to give your hair everything it
needs to look and feel its best you go
on there you tell them what's wrong with
your hair what you want to change about
it what you want to improve
and they give you your own specific
formulation
uh a bottle with your name on it every
product is sulfate and paraben free
vegan cruelty free and there are over 60
000 real
five star customer reviews function and
beauty fans are absolutely
wild about their fragrances and for good
reason
uh yeah like tiff's hair smells amazing
there's tropical mango
oh they have mango now yeah yeah they
didn't have that when i ordered last
year because they they
yeah they don't update their senses i
still have the christmas one the
christmas
it's christmas year-round yeah uh sweet
peach crisp
pear is that new no pearson there or
settler scents such as lavender my
favorite rose and eucalyptus which is
what
tiff is wearing and if you don't like
fragrance they can do unscented as well
um i've had the rose you've had
eucalyptus as my done like all
i like yeah i did peach i'm on peach
right now
it probably smells like hairspray right
now but i just cleaned it last night
they even have a what is it a hairspray
yeah that you can choose the color of
your shampoo and if you're blonde you
can choose purple oh yeah
yeah it helps those fake blonde yeah the
fake ones
like these fake [ __ ] here
[Laughter]
and they also have a really they used to
have a really cool black one that i like
oh yeah i got that one too
i forgot about that so go to
functionbeauty.com
big mood to take your quiz and save 20
on your first order
that applies to their full range of
customized hair skin and body products
because they got
body wash and lotion that's functional
beauty dot com slash big mood to let
them know you heard about it here
and to get 20 off your order and also of
course to support us
that's functionalbeauty.com big mood
mood and speaking of customizations
i want to talk about third love again
because if you're having problems with
your bra it's usually
because you're not getting a bra that
fits your boobies the way that they
should be
fitted in so like when you go to some
generic store usually they just measure
your boobs and give you like a general a
blanket
um size for your for your boobs but
sizings are always wrong
they're always wrong because there's so
many half sizes too that they don't
account for and third love actually has
a really big variety of sizes including
the half sizes and everything
also if you have one titty that's bigger
than the other titty then yeah if you
wear a generic bra then one titty is
like
like sitting up weird yeah yeah so they
go over what your current problems are
with your current bra
and then they work to fix them because
they can kind of tell like
what problem areas you are facing and
then
pick a bra that that fixes that and then
also pick out like your boob shape
like that matters too so the shape of
your bra should match the shape of your
boobs
so all kinds of stuff that you didn't
know go take the quiz online and then
there's a perfect fit promise they stand
behind their products so if you don't
love it
you can exchange it and exchanges and
returns are forever really really fast
i got like i got my return one this like
the day before i even mailed it back
like wow
yeah so it's really fast yeah so you
deserve some tlc that's third love
comfort go to thirdlove.com
big mood now to get 20 off your first
purchase that's thirdlove.com
big mood for 20 off today so tiffany
have you decided uh if you're going to
tell us anything
new yeah so i'll just make this quick
so i have been experiencing a lot of
symptoms on and off for many years
and i never really put much thought into
it i was just kind of like oh it went
away on its own
yeah like i'm fine you have waves yeah
it was like coming in waves
and one at one point um
months ago there was a fan who i'm sorry
i don't remember your name but shout
outs to you thank you so much he
he actually sent me a message and he was
like hey tiff i heard you talking about
some of your symptoms on jk news like
did you ever think about
did you ever think about getting tested
for lupus and i was like
what the heck like i've heard of what
lupus is but i didn't really fully
understand what it was
selena gomez yeah like she had to get a
kidney transplant
because of her lupus so lupus affects
people in
different ways like every person has a
different kind of it's an autoimmune
disorder yeah it's an autoimmune
disorder
and um and so i started googling it and
i'm like
holy [ __ ] i have almost all these
symptoms like i
i'm pretty damn convinced i think i
might have lupus
and the one symptom that really stood
out to me the most is the butterfly rash
which is is really like synonymous with
lupus and it's like this rash that goes
across your cheeks and your nose and
i get that sometimes and but sometimes
it goes away but most of the time i have
it so i'm like
what the [ __ ] is this like it can only
be lupus like i was convinced
yeah that's the one that got over the
edge right
so then i went to my my regular doctor
and he had me do an initial test it's
called an a
a where i guess they look at if you have
any anti
um autoimmune or i forgot what it's
called but like certain cells in your
blood work that show up that your body
is attacking itself like its own tissues
and so that first test came back
positive
which means i they did detect some of
those cells in my body so i was like
oh my god what does this mean this
sounds scary like does it mean i really
have lupus and my doctor was like calm
down like
a positive a a doesn't mean that you
have anything what you need to do now is
go to a specialist so
i found a rheumatologist and with that
rheumatologist she did
a second wave of like a more
comprehensive
a a and and so
yeah like she looked at that first blood
work and she was like oh this is really
strange that it even became
positive because all my organs are
working properly like everything's good
everything looked great um my liver was
like a little bit
under performing like a tiny bit but not
enough to like be worried about it
and so so yeah so then she was like
honestly
i think you know you don't have to freak
out
let's just look at the second set of
results and see what happens so the
second set of results came back she's
like yeah you don't have lupus like
or it's not you don't have anything in
your blood work that's strong enough for
me to say yes you have lupus right
but i have been experiencing a lot of
joint pain
and so what she concluded is that i have
this condition called uh palindromic
rheumatism
which is a very rare autoimmune uh
disease disorder i forget what's the
second word but it
it this thing eventually can turn into
rheumatoid arthritis
and my grandma which i didn't realize
until after i came back from mexico she
actually has rheumatoid arthritis oh
so then i told my rheumatologist about
that she was like okay well that's good
to know like marketing your chart
um she's like it doesn't necessarily
mean it's genetic
but yeah so pretty much that's kind of
like the conclusion to my health scare
is for sure like as of right now i
don't have a lupus diagnosis yeah but i
do have
a palindromic rheumatism
diagnosis which means that what it means
is that i'll have
waves of joint pain joint inflammation
joint stiffness
and the palindromic word means like
it'll
it'll be there at one point and it'll go
away and you'll be fine and
this specific time of uh this specific
type of
arthritis i guess it's classified as it
doesn't
it's not hurting my joints like it's not
causing damage to my joints like
rheumatoid arthritis like rheumatoid
exactly rheumatoid arthritis actually
like deteriorates your joints
um so it's kind of like pre-rheumatoid
arthritis
yeah but like cycles in and out not
super damaging but like still kind of
like
comfortable uncomfortable symptoms yeah
so that seems like okay like if it's
going to be anything exactly that seems
like yeah
the best case scenario yeah it because
we're all gonna get something like we're
all gonna [ __ ] cancer or some [ __ ]
you know like yeah
something but that was really the best
case scenario
out of anything like because at least i
have like
some sort of an answer as you know yeah
my joints are
painful like sometimes like they'll be
really achy and i just don't know why
and at least now i have an answer but
and so i asked her i'm like so where do
i go from here right like
is there medication i need to take and
she's like well if there is medication
it would be steroids and i'm like no
i do not want steroids you're not at
that point yeah yeah it's not until
you're old
does it have anything to do with like
how you get like you're like allergic to
the sun too
so i that's also that that's also
another condition that was so that was
one of the things that i thought lupus
lupus has that as a symptom too which is
called uh
photo photo sensitivity photosensitivity
and because i told her i'm like my
lifestyle has changed like i cannot be
in the sun
anymore i get these rashes i have to
wear a wetsuit whenever i go out to the
beach or something like it
my lifestyle has actually been affected
by this
thing now so she just marked that in my
in my chart like that's just another
condition that i have is
photosensitivity
so i don't know maybe it's not related
yeah i don't know
could be could not be right yeah she she
was
she pretty much said like for her types
of diseases that she diagnoses like
there's a ton of factors there's a lot
of things
what we really need now is like data so
i'm i'm supposed to see her every six
months now and
yeah i tell her like report on like what
how my symptoms have been
so it's good that you have a doctor like
watching it
so like if anything happens then you'll
be able to have some sort of
intervention probably before it gets
worse like if you had not gone and done
this then it could have yeah
it could have gotten worse without
anyone watching and usually when you
tackle something while it's still mild
then you have a much better outcome so
i'm glad you
actually went yeah like don't be afraid
to go to the doctor i know people are
like
i don't want to go because i'm going to
like have something and then in my whole
life
literally that was me for months i was
putting it off for
months about steve like terrifying dudes
like don't go to the hospital
until like it's so bad and he doesn't
talk about it either so it's not like i
even have any warning signs until it's
like he's on the floor in costa rica and
says he's gonna die yeah like if you get
into stuff
really you can treat it before it's so
bad like i don't know why people don't
but i guess like i because i i
understand that yeah
but i also understand why like i didn't
want to go to the doctor
because for me it was too scary to
know the truth like it was too much for
me to it was like my avoidance
a tendency and i'm like i'd rather like
if i ignore it maybe it won't
kind of like placebo you feel like if
you don't know it then maybe the
symptoms won't really
exactly and then also hearing like
there's a there's a saying that i
grew up hearing a lot which is and maybe
that also contributed to me not wanting
to find out is the diagnosis
kills you more than the disease because
like you end up
like hurting yourself more emotionally
mind over matter right
yeah so then that's another reason why i
was like
settle into being a victim of a disease
yes versus
worse exactly like if you know that
that's like a thing
that's you can kind of like you cannot
be that like
people get cancer and they beat it
people get different disorders and
diseases and stuff and then they beat it
so
you don't have to be taken down by a
diagnosis either so right crazy april
dude
[ __ ] yeah there was even more stuff
but we won't talk about it right now
um man like i don't i guess like i
lately i've been having a lot more like
mental breakthroughs
so i started seeing a new therapist um
in early april so it's been like is your
old therapist think about you seeing a
new life
my old therapist was awesome i actually
recommended her to gina but she has a
program where you complete it in 10
weeks she doesn't do continual she
doesn't do continue
it's i guess it's called something like
cbt or something where
you you change like the root of your
behavior
or like you you really dig up your
childhood yeah and then you change like
your coping mechanism so she gave me a
lot of good tools that have lasted this
long so i last went to her like almost
five years ago now
and um but then like lately
i've i've been having almost like ptsd
symptoms
and i've never had ptsd before but i'm
pretty sure that
it is um that and there was an event
that happened last year that i
like was getting the most ptsd from but
after seeing this therapist like she's
pointed out that there are several other
really traumatic events that have
happened in the past decade or so
that i kind of had suppressed and so it
kind of all
culminated to a point last year where
now
it's not just that i'm getting triggered
because of
stuff that happened last year but also
from all these other events that i've
suppressed and they're
like she always says like the body keeps
the score yeah there's that book you
know the body keeps scoring i haven't
read it yet she said i'm not ready to
read it
but um basically you know your body
you're not responsible in your mind for
your traumas when you're like hey i'm
over it like get over it
you know it gets stored in your body in
your nervous system
and so when certain triggers happen
you can't just mentally be like no
that's not a danger like your body
thinks it's in this other country with
adrenaline and things and you're not in
control of your brain releasing
chemicals like
you know like the reaction that you have
there's like a mind-body separation
where your mind and body are in two
different places your body is still
reliving this trauma that happened
and your mind is like yo we're not there
anymore but i can't stop you from
feeling this way and so i was getting
like lots of panic attacks and stuff
and working with her i've had so many
breakthroughs
um and i haven't had a panic attack
since i started working with her
it also was the same time that i got
diagnosed with adhd
and got put on medication which i'm on
the mildest dosage because i'm so like
weird about medication but um all of
that
like has helped me find this like
clarity that has been really
life-changing like i really
have never been more grateful for this
time in my
like for living in my life ever
just so weird because a couple months
ago i was like in a really depressed
point
where i was like i don't i feel like i
can't go on you know and like
so now it's been like so 180 like where
i'm
so grateful that i'm scared of losing it
which is like yeah which is uh it's
awesome because i'm like
every day i'm like so thankful but
lately i've been going through these
things where
i'm just like wait i can never i can't
keep this like i want to just
keep all of this moment this life right
now as it is like
in a bottle and just hold on to it
forever and like stay like groundhog's
day like stay in this
this [ __ ] life right now it's like
the best i've ever felt something
coming that ruins things yeah and so i'm
like waiting for the other shoe to drop
which is no way to live either because
then you're not really present you're
you're still giving yourself anxiety for
things that haven't happened yet
instead of just living in the moment and
being thankful for it so i've been
really struggling um the past couple
weeks with nostalgia
because i remodeled i remodeled our
rooms jess relates hard
um so i remodeled our two of our rooms
the kitchen pantry
area and that's really good by the way
yeah do you have it
i'm not on instagram hardly ever but did
you do it on the nikki home
um yeah on house of limos house of limo
there you go it looks so
good now thank you yeah it's i love
remodeling
different rooms and like just picking it
out and having it all come together but
it took
quite a few days like a solid like four
like four days straight
of working on them for like eight to 12
hours a day
and uh during that time i was listening
to 90s music and usually like 90s music
it's just my go-to just like pumps me up
it keeps me energized
but uh while i was listening to it like
on the second day
something weird happened where it took
me back to like my own
my own personal life in the 90s like
because generally the 90s feels light to
me
and feels like a simpler time but we're
children too so
yeah but we were kids and then it's just
in my head it got
locked in as this like simpler time
where no social media exists and you're
just like
just like free and wild and like it's
more of a hippie at times
and but then this time it brought me
back to my actual childhood in the 90s
which was like really lonely
and i started like getting like really
sad about it um because it was like
really
kind of a heavy time and but then i also
got really thankful for how light this
time is and so i was
talking to my therapist about like this
how to
how to kind of reconcile these two
energies where i feel this like
nostalgia for the 90s and also this
heaviness and then also this like
this like feeling of okay here's what it
really is is that like the 90s feels
like it was just a couple years ago for
me
but it was 30 [ __ ] years ago and to
think that like
this time right now that i could go by
in a blink of an eye that i'm like oh my
god i miss that time in my life
which is why i'm trying so hard to grasp
to the present
of like i love this time so much like i
don't ever want to let it go
and she was like hey you know what um
you never really lose anything you know
your memories and everything in your
life is like a river
and there's no beginning or end so if
you picture a river
and you're like you start you're like
floating on the river and you're a baby
and then you're a child and you're a
teenager and then you're a young adult
and then now you're
a grown adult like you are right now
like you're still all of those things
you're still baby nicki you're still
child nicki you're still teenage nikki
and so
those will come in from time to time
like they'll visit you basically like
teenage nikki will visit you or child
nikki will visit you
but you they live inside you they don't
go away and so as things go on like
your time period right now is not you're
not going to lose it
it's not going to go away you don't ever
lose anything nothing's ever lost and i
was like
well what about the people in my life
right now like if i lost my husband i
would i don't know how i would continue
life like he's like my
everything and and my friend group right
now and like
my family's all healthy like i was
spending a lot of time with my family
lately
and they just bring me so much joy and
i'm like i don't know how
how long i'm gonna get these moments
with these people and it was just really
like getting
getting to me and she's like have you
ever lost anyone i was like yep well i
lost my grandma but it was like she had
alzheimer's for 10 years and so i felt
like i lost her slowly over time
and um and she had me like describe my
grandma and like memories i had with her
and she was like wow it sounds like
you're really close to grandma and i was
we were really close she was a young
grandma she became a grandma at 44.
and um so she was always like this young
spry teenage grandma i thought i was
going to have her for the rest of my
life
and then she was the first one to go and
it did really
hurt me in a way that i didn't process
fully and but she's like but she's still
with you because i can hear her
in your voice and your memories like she
had a big impact on you she was the one
that
that brought me into the entertainment
industry she was a professional extra
and she was such a ham and she she loved
like
just like going being in the background
and trying to get close to the main
actors
she just loved being on tv like she
didn't even want to be an actor she just
liked being
center stage and probably front and
center and i think like she
imparted a lot of her personality on me
and
and she's like so yeah so she still
lives in you and i'm like yeah she
visits me in my dream sometimes and like
she's like yeah
she really does because she's still part
of you and so you never lose those
things and
she talked about like how when you have
like a rose bush
you know the roses they bloom and
they're so pretty and fragrant and then
they fall off like they fall off the
bush
but the bush lives on and the bush keeps
living and the next year it grows roses
again
and that's how life is and like nothing
it never really ends it just like
and so i've decided i really do want
kids
it would be a shame to have it end with
me
you know like you guys kept going back
and forth and back and forth we were so
on the fence forever
oh yeah steve was like nah yeah we were
both like we love our
so thank you for listening so you're
getting noted it on a nightly
yeah they're getting so nutted in
so much nutting i'm thinking about that
on our couch right now
probably does that turn you on i don't
want to sit on that but
it's the wet spot
thank you so much for listening
everybody if you want to um help us out
you could check out our sponsors you
could also rate us on itunes that helps
a lot and you could also subscribe on
youtube
follow us on instagram all kinds of ways
to support the show if you're into that
but if not thanks for watching the whole
episode like i said
is optional but please do but do it
support gina on g4
and jess in texas yeah
[Laughter]
yeah they see me rolling by they're like
oh god i don't talk like exciting
they'll leave me alone now there's like
a warning sign for the mailman
from now on beware of white woman yeah
it's a never-ending war between her and
that security guy yeah every time i see
each other
every time i see the maintenance guy
roll by i'm like [ __ ] you buddy
he kills the bushes outside of your
house snitch [ __ ] on your golf cart
she pops his tires yeah it's just back
and forth it's getting ugly man
i will see you next time guys bye